he is one man
from one of many troubling legacies of
this long war
his name is shabib ali shabib he's 21
and he's accused of being a member of
the islamic state
we've been given exclusive access to his
trial the islamic state was defeated
two years ago thousands of isis fighters
survived
and one by one in a basic courthouse
with no funding and no
help a few dedicated and brave lawyers
are bringing them to justice
[Music]
there are three judges two men and a
woman
we can't show you their faces they worry
for their lives
the isis caliphate may have been
defeated but followers remain in the
community
the chief judge reads a long list of
charges
the charges suggest he was 16 when he
was recruited by isis
with each suspect more evidence is
revealed about the islamic state
how it operated its network the key
[Music]
players
[Music]
doesn't have a lawyer at this stage of
the hearing but he will be offered one
at his next appearance
here's the challenge the authorities
face beyond the legal process
cctv given to sky news shows some of the
12
000 men awaiting trial and being held
dozens to a cell
in an inadequate prison watch here as
they bang on the door
and here as a guard checks on them they
thrust a pole through the hatch
there have been at least two mass riots
in this prison
in november 2019 we went inside hello
and met some of the thousands of
foreigners no i'm german
germans americans and a british man
ishaq mustafa
i was within the islamic state living
under the islamic state
he's now dead killed in an attempted
escape
the authorities have repeatedly said
they need international help to secure
the prisons
and to try the suspects the woman
overseeing the thousands of trials that
need to take place
asked that her identity and her voice be
changed through a translator she said
that if countries won't take their
people back
an international court must be set up
here in syria
uh really they must do something for
these prisoners
it's a big risk on all over the world
not only on
syria on rojava it's a it's a global
problem
they see the scene in syria with daesh
like they are watching just a film just
a short film and they don't
regard to the the risk on the people
all over the world shabee
will return for his next hearing in the
coming weeks he'll be followed by
thousands more
into this single courtroom mark stone
sky news
in kurdish controlled northeast and
syria